we simply decided that
we were going to call it Apple Computer
unless some suggested a better
name by five o'clock that day
and partially
because
I like apples a lot...
and partially
because Apple is ahead of Atari in the
phone book
But, we re examined it
on a regular basis
and we found the juxtaposition of something
that seemed to epitomize what we were going after
which was simplicty, and yet
very refined sophistication.
and, in our first brochure, probably some of you had it, had the...
the title of it was "Simplicity is the ultimate
sophistication."
and that wasn't just a
bullshit slogan, it actually was
really what
we've been striving for
and the...
apple seemed to symbolize that.
So,
I think we are going to stich with it.